Anthony denoon is analyzing his
basketball statistics the following
table shows a probability model for the
result from his next two free-throws and
so it has various outcomes of those two
free-throws and then the corresponding
probability missing both free-throws 0.2
making exactly one free-throw 0.5 and
making both free-throws 0.1 is this a
valid probability model pause this video
and see if you can make a conclusion
there so let's talk about what makes a
valid probability model 1 the sum of the
probabilities of all the scenarios need
to add up to 100% so we would definitely
want to check that and also they would
all have to be positive values or I
guess I should say they can none of them
can be negative values you could have a
scenario that has a 0% probability and
so all of these look like positive
probabilities so we meet that second
test that all the probabilities are
non-negative but do they add up to 100%
so if I had point two to 0.5 that is 0.7
plus 0.1 they add up to 0.8 or they add
up to 80% so this is not a valid
probability model in order for it to be
valid they with all all the various
scenarios need to add up exactly to 100%
in this case we only add up to 80% if
this if we added up to 1.1 or 110% then
we would also have a problem but we can
just write no let's do another example
so here we are told you are a space
alien you visit Planet Earth and abduct
97 chickens 47 cows and 77 humans then
you randomly select one earth creature
from your sample to experiment on each
creature has an equal probability of
getting selected create a probability
model to show how likely you are to
select each type of earth creature input
your answers as fractions or as decimals
around
to the nearest hundred so in the last
example we wanted to see where the
probability model was was valid was
legitimate here we want to construct a
legitimate probability model well how
would we do that well the estimated
probability of getting a chicken is
going to be the fraction that you're
sampling from that is our chickens
because any one of the animals are
equally likely to be selected 97 of the
97 plus 47 plus 77 animals are chickens
and so what is this going to be this is
going to be 97 over 97 47 and 77 you add
them up three sevens is 21 and then
let's see 2 plus 9 is 11 plus 4 is 15
plus 7 is 22 so 221 so 97 of the 221
animals or chickens and so I'll just
write 97 to 20 ones they say that we can
answer as fraction so I'm just going to
go that way what about cows well
forty-seven of the 221 are cows so
there's a forty seven to twenty first
probability of getting a cow and then
last but not least you have 77 of the
221 our human is this a legitimate
probability distribution we'll add these
up if you add these three fractions up
the denominator is going to be 221 and
we already know that 97 plus 47 plus 77
is 221 so it definitely adds up to one
and none of these are negative so this
is a legitimate probability distribution